[Musique]
sonia porot bonjour bonjour avenue mère
installée vous pour ce café politique
vous êtes une femme de gauche
responsable de la cgt dans le
département des yvelines est ce que
étiquette de femmes de gauche les chats
pour commencer ça vous convient
progressiste oui certainement
c'est aussi souvent ce qu'on associe à
la gauche mais vraiment attachés aux os
syndicalisme et au fait que les salariés
puissent prendre un peu plus leur destin
en main vous avez moins de 40 ans cette
fibre de gauche vous l'avez toujours eu
très jeune ça a commencé très jeune
l'engagement relativement oui puisque
j'ai eu mes premiers engagements au
lycée à l'époque j'étais à toulon et
venait d'avoir une une mairie front
national élu en 95
j'ai vu les
les conséquences des politiques menées
par ce parti sur la culture sur la vie
associative
donc ça a été mon premier engagement et
puis ensuite j'ai été aussi beaucoup
engagé sur les questions de précarité de
soutien aux sans papiers quand j'ai eu
mon premier emploi stable je me suis
syndiquée à la cgt
le mois d'après alors c'était pas
d'engagement politique c'était
nécessairement pour vous un engagement
syndicaliste ça passait par sa oui oui
je pense que la particularité du
syndicalisme c'est que vraiment on a
tous en commun cette condition de
salariés donc des choses qu'on
partageons ce qu'on vit au travail ou
après le travail vous l'accès à l'emploi
et que ça crée vraiment des conditions
de débat est reconstruction ensemble qui
sont différentes des partis politiques
ça veut dire qu'une évolution en ce qui
vous concerne vers la politique c'est
pas envisageable c'est pas quelque chose
qui m'intéresse à l'heure actuelle quel
regard vous avez sur les politiques sur
la classe politique parle parle pas
forcément on parle pas forcément de
partis politiques mais sur l'aspect
politique
je vous avoue que je suis tellement
concentré dans tout ce qu'on a à faire
en tant qu'organisations syndicales pour
mieux toucher tous les salariés pour
défendre pour vous la politique est
déconnecté de la réalité ou plus je
pense que forcément le syndicalisme
c'est s'aider des salariés des chômeurs
des retraités qui sont dans les
entreprises dans les administrations
donc vraiment on a une prise sur sur le
réel qui est forcément plus forte que
celle des partis politiques et on le
voit aussi dans nos effectifs les
organisations syndicales ont nettement
plus d'adhérents que les parties même si
on estime que ce n'est pas encore
suffisant et plus on sera nombreux à
s'engager à faire avancer nos conditions
de travail et de vie mieux ce sera parce
que tout de même une régression ces
dernières années du nombre de syndiqués
des personnes qui franchissent le pas
vers l'essentiel notamment à la cgt
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt stable on a
énormément
d'adhésion très très régulièrement mais
on a aussi bien des départs à la
retraite on a aussi l'instabilité du
monde du travail qui fait que c'est
compliqué de suivre des syndiqués qui
sont en cdd sont en intérim change
d'entreprise voire deux départements et
c'est quelque chose qu'on travaille pour
pouvoir accompagner nos syndiqués dans
leur évolution professionnelle dans les
yvelines aujourd'hui la cgt on
représente quoi
on est huit mille 200 syndiqués dans le
département est-ce que c'est suffisant
pour vous est-ce que c'est un chiffre
qui est stable est ce que c'est un
chiffre qui est plutôt en légère
progression
en tout cas on ne régresse pas c'est
suffisant non parce que il ya encore des
de nombreux salariés con qu'on touche
pas dans les très petites entreprises
pour lesquelles on a fait campagne en
2016 et on veut continuer parce que
c'est quand même à peu près 15 % des
salariés millois mieux toucher les
femmes montrer aux ingénieurs cadres et
techniciens qu'on a des propositions et
un travail sur des sujets qui qui les
intéressent les salariés du commerce qui
sont qui sont très nombreux aussi on va
parler de votre carrière professionnelle
aussi parce que vous êtes engagés sur
une autre à syndicats au niveau de la
cgt mais vous travaillez à côté
ne serait-ce que un travail tout même
prenant aussi téléconseillère pour une
société d'assurance c'est ça tout à fait
oui très fatigant oui bah c'est ça c'est
sur le modèle des centres d'appels donc
effectivement c'est c'est fatigant après
les les centres d'appels moi j'ai
toujours en effet plusieurs il ya
toujours une très forte solidarité entre
collègues c'est souvent ce qui fait ce
qui fait tenir dans ce métier et puis le
sens du service
par rapport aux personnes qui nous
appellent et qu'ils ont et qui ont des
besoins c'est c'est aussi voilà ce qui
permet de tenir dans le travail
et dans tous les métiers difficiles
notamment c'est la volonté d'être utile
à d'autres essais ce métier aussi qui
fait que vous avez besoin envie d'être
syndiqué pour faire valoir vos droits
pour vous faire entendre
oui moi moi je me suis je me suis
syndiqué aussi parce que j'avais envie
de changer des choses dans dans la
manière dont doit être organisé le
travail voilà les phrases imposer le
fait pas être suffisamment bien formés
d'avoir plus de temps pour pouvoir
répondre aux personnes qui nous
appellent
c'était aussi des choses qui m'ont
motivé en 2009 vous êtes responsable de
la cgt sur saint quentin en yvelines la
2015 responsable départemental le
passage sur saint quentin en yvelines a
apporté quoi pour l'expérience
ensuite au niveau yvelinois c'est
représentatif on a un département qui
est quand même grand et constraste et
puisqu'on a quand même des partis plus
plus rurales dans le département on a
toute la zone autour de mende qui parle
celle où il ya le plus fort taux de
chômage
mais oui saint quentin en yvelines c'est
très représentatif du du département au
global avec une très forte concentration
d'ingénieurs cadres et techniciens
vraiment énormément d'emplois dans le
commerce et les services
donc ça m'a montré oui les enjeux du
syndicalisme d'aujourd'hui par rapport
aux réalités des salariés du département
cet engagement syndicaliste il a
toujours existé dans votre famille non
moi je viens d'une famille
de gauche où on débattait beaucoup
effectivement de l'actualité de sujets
comme ça mais plus de manière
philosophique que j'ai pas j'ai pas une
famille très concrètement engagé et vous
les avez pas motivé aujourd'hui les
membres de votre famille à se syndiquer
dans mon père si elles sont indiquées
pas mais pas réussi à convaincre nom et
ma plus jeune soeur qui est infirmière a
été aussi sans doute et syndiqué à la
cgt
quand elles quand elles travaillent dans
ce secteur là les discussions en famille
tourne toujours autour d'eux des
syndicats de la politique
oui bon on discute oui on discute aussi
de concrètement ça veut dire quoi être
engagée comment comme on le fait de
manière à écouter les syndics et les
salariés pour vraiment être porteur de
leurs besoins de l'heure de leur
inspiration sur les grands sujets de
société
aujourd'hui quel besoin de protection
sociale il ya un sujet qui touche
aujourd'hui tout le monde sait les
questions de vieillissement comment on
prend en charge les personnes âgées la
perte d'autonomie ça c'est un vrai sujet
de société où qu'on soit salariés de ces
secteurs là où
ou futurs usagers ou proches de
personnes âgées ça nous concerne et je
pense qu'il ya des très grands progrès à
faire dans notre pays
pour bien traiter nos anciens est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment qu'aujourd'hui
les salariés sont mieux protégés que par
le passé n'ont pas pas vraiment il y
avait besoin justement des salariés la
cgt on a par exemple une proposition
qu'on appelle nouveau statut du travail
salarié la sécurité sociale
professionnelle
on sait que la rotation dans les
entreprises a vraiment beaucoup augmenté
que même si la majorité des gens sont en
cdi
il ya quand même beaucoup de cdd et
d'intérim de contrats précaires et cette
proposition c'est à dire les gens des
droits qui sont transférables une
entreprise à l'autre et qui leur
permettre de progresser pas de repartir
à zéro à chaque fois qu'ils changent
d'entreprise et aujourd'hui c'est pas
sais pas ce qui se passe puisque avec
les dernières réformes sur le droit du
travail ce qui s'annonce sur la fonction
publique c'est plutôt diminuer les
protections et diminuer les garanties
collectives commune à tous et ça ça
fragilise et les salariés vous avez des
inquiétudes aujourd'hui par rapport aux
annonces qui peuvent être faites par le
gouvernement
oui on c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on
qu'on est dans un processus de
mobilisation à la fois pour empêcher les
ordonnances de se mettre en place dans
les entreprises et permettre aux
salariés de mieux s'emparer de ce qui
concerne leur travail la diminution des
des emplois dans la fonction publique
alors qu'il ya des besoins importants
il ya déjà eu des mobilisations fortes
et ça se poursuit de manière unitaire
donc c'est pas c'est vraiment pas que la
cgt qui qui est alarmé
et évidemment dans le privé aussi par
rapport à la la précarité aux conditions
de travail aux horaires et aux salaires
il ya aussi beaucoup de mécontentement
et des mobilisations dans de nombreuses
entreprises
si on parle des moyens d'action à
présent parce que c'est aussi ça qui
fait parlé quelques fois sur la façon
d'agir des syndicats est ce que tous les
moyens sont bons pour se faire entendre
à tous tous les moyens en tout cas il
n'y a pas une seule forme d'actions
quand les assistantes maternelles par
exemple pour lesquelles on a un syndicat
ont fait un rassemblement même si elle
était que quelques dizaines je pense que
c'était déjà un grand pas franchi pour
des métiers très dévalorisée mon mal
perçu je pense aux trains bloqués des
choses comme ça qui peuvent être mal
perçu dans l'opinion publique
oui après je pense que jusqu'à
maintenant un certain nombre de
mouvements ont été plutôt a très
largement soutenue par l'opinion il faut
aussi bien qu'on m'explique pourquoi les
cheminots par exemple se mobiliser quand
ils font grève
ouais il ya moins de trains qui roulent
mais c'est aussi pour défendre la
sécurité et les conditions de transport
des usagers et pas juste pour défendre
un statut qui qui est aussi liée à leur
condition travail je sais pas si vous
avez eu un planning de cheminots mais
enfin pour avoir une vie personnelle une
vie de famille c'est quand même très
compliqué pour bien trop terminer cet
entretien j'aimerais aussi profiter de
votre présence et du fait que vous soyez
une femme pour me dire si le monde
syndicalistes et est assez féminisé ou
pas pas assez mais c'est en progression
est en tout cas c'est
c'est un combat très fort de la cgt
aussi bien en interne que vis-à-vis des
salariés
on a un travail à part des instances qui
sont paritaires pour accompagner la
prise de responsabilité des femmes est
en tout cas au niveau du département on
est on est plutôt en progression à ce
niveau là il reste encore beaucoup à
conquérir ça c'est sûr sûr sûr l'égalité
mais on y travaille
voilà pour le pour le 10 mars il ya eu
des initiatives dans dans les
entreprises par exemple et traiter ce
sujet là c'est ça nous a amené des
adhésions un petit questionnaire pour
terminer france insoumise ou parti
communiste dany ni l'un ni l'un ni
l'autre
moi vraiment mon engagement et se situe
dans dans un autre dans un autre cadre
négociations une manifestation les deux
les deux vont de pair
on négocie d'abord on manifeste après
rond dans quel sens six mois ça ça
dépend des salariés des types de
négociations mais oui en tout cas on
pense à la cgt que si on montre pas
le mécontentement ou les besoins des
salariés alors à travers des
manifestations des pétitions des
rassemblements pas ça qu'on est moins
pris en compte dans les négociations
hausse des salaires ou rtt à l'ailé
d'heure il a aussi claqué ou pas je ne
pouvais pas choisir
non mais parce qu'on porte justement un
projet de réduction du temps de travail
qui doit permettre de créer des emplois
mais sans perte de salaire parce
qu'aujourd'hui les richesses créées dans
ce pays elles sont importantes mais
elles sont de plus en plus capté par les
actionnaires plutôt qu'investir dans
l'emploi et les conditions de travail ou
dans le
les entreprises les machines etc merci
on a pu rocky étaient invités donc de ce
café politique merci à vous
[Musique]